Qué tan efectiva puede llegar a ser esta
requisición anunciada por el gobierno
francés
Bueno es un conflicto social duro y
efectivamente es una batalla jurídica
que emprende el gobierno con esta
requisición de trabajadores legalmente
tiene derecho a hacerlo Pero tiene que
demostrar que es una medida necesaria
para mantener el orden público lo que es
complicado y antecedentes de de estas
medidas que han sido anuladas por el
consejo de estado en Francia Entonces es
una batalla jurídica y detrás una
batalla política como siempre con este
tipo de conflicto con la opinión pública
arbitrando
ahora el gobierno hizo saber que tomaría
las medidas que calificó como medidas
necesarias para levantar las huelgas de
Qué medidas podríamos estar hablando
Pues se trata se trataría de
requisicionar trabajadores para hacer
funcionar las refinerías para alimentar
el país en gasolina porque en este
momento hay una escasez de gasolina en
más o menos un tercio de las gasolineras
del país lo que evidentemente afecta a
la economía y la toda la actividad del
país Entonces se trataría de obligar
Esos trabajadores a trabajar a hacer sus
tareas con su pena de de multas
eventualmente Hay penas de cárceles que
se podrían pronunciar en el en caso de
Esos trabajadores se negarán a hacerlo
repito con con esta este interrogante
sobre la legalidad de las medidas y la
batalla jurídica que seguramente se va a
emprender alrededor de esto ahora Qué
impacto tienen estas huelgas para los
franceses en medio de una crisis
energética que aumenta y afecta casi que
a la mayoría de Europa a raíz de la
guerra en Ucrania
sí evidentemente es una es una huelga
que afecta muy directamente los
franceses en su en su trabajo o en sus
vidas cotidianas no con con estas
gasolineras que no que no tienen
combustible y evidentemente eso alimenta
un poco la prueba de fuerza entre
las organizaciones sindicales y y esos
dos grandes grupos y con el gobierno hay
detrás
Por una parte son son medidas de presión
por parte de los jueguistas que son que
que siempre amenazan con ser impopulares
por otra parte de esos grupos son
también impopulares en este momento y
acusados de hacer sobre beneficios
aprovechando un poco la crisis del
sector energético por la escasez de vida
al conflicto en Ucrania entonces bueno
todo esto pesa en la opinión pública